il a conquis le monde entier
c'est jérôme mesnager l'inventeur du
moulin blanc s'expose carrément et parle
de son art ménages et bien sûr 11-0
ménagers bonsoir peuvent pas tout à fait
l'école boulle d'abord est un diplômé en
79 aurait ensuite les cours de bd got et
pichard à l'école des arts appliqués il
ya des cours de bel et bien sûr au
visage un beau inscrire en auditeur
libre alors en 1981 tu faisais mon
service militaire à trèves en allemagne
lorsque tu apprends la mort de malaval
et il décide de devenir le peintre de la
vitesse de la vie voilà c'est pas
l'autre
[Applaudissements]
et
on a commencé à faire des performances
dans des lieux désaffectés des abattoirs
des gares des usines en finlande et en
droit comme ça un peu laissés pour
compte
il y avait que tu as participé à des
associations et ce sans poudre d'or et
l'association ac dans la jungle dans la
savane
alors là tu me paies ni en blanc ouais
dans ces lieux et je faisais vivre
l'homme blanc est ce que tu pourrais
signé en blanc et ut appuyé contre le
mur un peu comme l'idée d'un corps qui
se promènent la banlieue et j'ai évolué
là dedans
le but de zigzag dans la savane cessé
d'inviter des artistes dans un lieu un
lieu en démolition ou un lieu abandonné
et d'en faire un lieu d'art pour une
journée donc c'était un dimanche par
mois et on faisait venir des musiciens
des des rockers des danseurs et cetera
des peintres et il fallait donc utiliser
le lieu tel qu'il était et en tirer le
meilleur parti en venant avec rien sept
principaux impôts de ceinture pour le
pain est donc c'est dans cette idée dans
ces lieux que j'ai eu cette idée de
faire un déplacement d'un corps idéal
dans un lieu qui devenait intenable et
la carotte et le corps blanc voilà un
vécu lorsqu'il faut préciser sur le
corps blanc au départ c'est que ce
n'était pas du pochoir et ce n'était pas
de la bombe
c'était en quelques coups de pinceau
comme ça wen en road l'association vivre
il s'agit plus d'une idée d'un message
que j'avais envie de porter c'est à dire
cette idée de me libre je voulais créer
un être idéal ouais pour que chacun
retrouve un petit peu son idéal qu'ils
soient ni historique ni social parce qu
rebours a commencé à le voir d'abord sur
des troncs d'arbres sur les palissades
et après il ya une invasion mondiale
dans la vie par tout d'abord on l'a vu
sur les berges de la seine et puis
ensuite allé faire le tour du monde vous
les avez mis un peu partout voilà dans
mon message exact
et donc j'ai voulu répondre après et en
même temps l'expression pure se passe
dans le fait de donner un maximum de soi
distribuer son image
on regarde tout ça elle était allée bon
en europe aux usa tu es allé sur les
pires amis étaient même allés sur la
grande muraille de chine tend à fait sur
la grande muraille de chine qu'est-ce
qui s'est sûrement et soutenons mais
passionnant ce que tu as fait un bouquin
en 88 je savais comment le tour du monde
du bonhomme est donc là c'est une série
de photos dont il de ce corps qui se
promènent et qui qui est visible par
chaque civilisation 900 chaque peuple tu
en as fait combien au jour d'aujourd'hui
les corps blanc ça dans le monde
j'aurais du mal à dire des milliers oui
mais c'est pas compter les milliers et
pour les autorisations comment tu fais
parce que bon il est beau mon besoin de
la permission par contre les berges de
la seine c'est la mairie de paris qui a
autorisé
c'était une commande plus ou moins la
mairie de paris pour fait l'effort doit
porter sur les pyramides sur la muraille
de chine tu es obligée de danser avec
les autorités dans la nuit
ah bon ce qui compte c'est que le
message passe ouais t'as jamais l'ennui
jamais eu envie en chine quand même j'ai
marché sur la muraille de chine
au delà de la partie restaurée ceci dit
j'ai pas un à shanghai en milieu de la
ville pour tous les chinois vivent
dehors et sortir ce spectable trottoirs
et là c'est le premier vrai rapport que
j'ai eues avec les chinois pour tandis
que j'ai pas là j'avais pas la
communication par la parole parce qu'on
n'a pas la même langue et donc j'ai fait
les bonnes homme blanc je n'étais plus
touristes banalement sorti les
bouteilles de bière ils m'ont invité à
venir boire un pot c'est la première
fois colérique et avec eux alors ils ont
invité à boire un peu alors après tu as
commencé à en faire sur les assemblages
de toile sur les palissades disons
démontable sur des déchets urbains et
l'acte comme ça qu'à lyon les galeries
quand même après avoir fait tout ce
travail autour du monde elle se
travaille sur sur la rue j'ai vu cette
idée de prendre des morceaux de la rue
et d'y intégrer donc des fragments d'os
d'hommes blancs comme si on prenait un
polaroïd ou une photo d'un coin de la
rue et qu'on le mettait pour la
postérité quand le préserver
l'avenir est là ça pouvait devenir
tableau les gagnants d'autant plus que
le bonhomme blanc ils en rencontrent
d'autres il a des aventures maintenant
les tableaux célèbres où il enlace est
en train de s'embrasser avec un os de la
main c'est un peu comme tout avec
l'élite voilà implique une tablette et
le monde du mariage il ya même eu des
maternités au mans
oui on aime à terme moyen expo à la
galerie là et alors il ya une expo
événement bien entendu au mois d'avril à
partir du 14 non non c'est une expo
énorme ça la mairie de lille cette fois
je reprends tout l'histoire de l'art
comme territoires d'exploration du
bonhomme bien et donc sa part des
grandes de la souche un produit partout
où elle passe par le moyen-âge ça passe
par l'art de tous les pays et le
bonhomme bloc se promènent là dedans
comme un territoire précis
alors évidemment ça va demander des
années de travail pour recopier chaque
tableau chaque ville la joconde lewis
diallo et tout ça j'ai obligé
d'apprendre l'histoire de l'art la même
rêver jusqu'à l'art contemporain et le
bonhomme ce sont les liens sa grande
balade ya les particuliers quittant
commande aussi présente chez moi si je
document passera tout l'enfer c'est
possible c'est possible peut-être temps
demandé alors tu mais combien de temps
pour en faire un bonhomme blanc dans le
jeu mais 23 secondes
non tu mettais 26-25 vente est arrivé à
23 10 records actifs et des records
c'est pas du ballon non mais quand j'ai
pas les berges de la seine y avait un
bateau mouche
suivez le parcours et j'avance et à la
vitesse du bateau mouche soir là j'ai dû
vendre extrêmement vite mais comme je
disais le peintre de la vitesse ouais
j'ai été influencé par qui pourquoi pas
disons dans les grands concepts qui
importe qui m'a énormément marqué c'est
yves klein avec son idée de des
peintures universal france 2
sans aucune dimension du côté absolue
aussi des choses ensuite est bon tout
l'engagement de sa vie vis-à-vis de la
peinture ça c'est des choses qui m'ont
très marquée malaval j'en ai parlé
et puis plus récemment des gens comme
ernest pignon-ernest qu'à travailler
dans hermès tient si le produit est
quelqu'un que j'adore et puis gérard
zlotykamien qui dans les années soixante
bombes et des personnages éphémères
donc à la bombe passée il ya un art de
la rue qui existe et ça c'est des choses
qui m'ont marqué aussi dans ma jeunesse
et copier il y avait des faux bonhomme
blanc jouant comme nous alors on les
reconnaît dans des gros devoir mater à
voir mais c'est vrai qu'un jour je suis
passé vers d'amérique la rencontre est
un type qui faisait comme toi non c'est
un américain qui fait des ombres noires
c'est un mois donc maintenant c'est un
bloc maintenant l'écart à 4 3 ans
puisque moi et son travail suppose la
présente vingt corps d'une lumière
le corps très parti et l'ombre reste
inquiétant mais en même temps c'est un
espace de rencontre il arrive à créer un
esprit de rencontre on a l'impression
qu'il ya quelqu'un et il est venu en
faire à paris à côté des bonhommes bleus
ont donc on note une petite chatte tant
qu'international ouais tu serais qui si
tu étais pas jérôme mesnager
à ton avis sera peut-être un animal un
oiseau un oiseau ça sert à quoi est ce
que tu fais avec ce tome et le bonheur
j'avais une définition de toi dans un
dictionnaire tu aimerais que ce soit
quoi
l'éternel bonheur mais possible c'est à
dire que je suis idéaliste sans être
utopiste
j'y crois et j'ai avec tout le monde y
croit et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu